you may have noticed the weirdly  patterned parachute in nasa's recently  released landing footage on mars  one eagle eye twitter user figured out  how to decode the secret message that  lay within that pattern  by assuming these red and white panels  were coding for binary ones and zeros  let's see what the innermost ring says  the ring is split into eight equal  sections each representing  10 bit sequences these sequences are  coding for numbers  a simple number cipher where the numbers  represent  letters in the alphabet these sections  have numbers higher than 26  and are assumed to be junk code  translating this  then provides the word dare the first  word in jpl's motto  dare mighty thinks and indeed mighty  things  are both coded into the next two  concentric circles of the shoot  the outermost section is a mixture of  numbers and letters and provides us with  the gps coordinates for jbl's lab in  pasadena california